the Joe Rogan experience what is that
Deonte Walters gator-skin
no more pictures yeah what do you do
listen first of all that's a rap okay
that's not real skin it's a rap
what if it was reals gator-skin they
would have to glue it to the car there's
like divots on the little things
hush your mouth that's not I have an
alligator skin I hate alligators so if
you know this I don't like him I don't I
don't talk about it too much but I'd
like a hate for scared of them yeah yeah
when I was a little kid I lived in
Florida when I live in Gainesville from
age 11 and we lived near a place called
Lake Alice and lay cows had alligators
and I knew there was a lady that was
walking her out of her walking hiking
walking her dog by the lake and the
alligator came out and snatched her
[ __ ] dog solid and I didn't see it I
didn't see it but I remember that being
a thing and I've ever seen those goddamn
things all the time and everybody
telling me that you don't have to worry
about it
when I'm 11 like my sister my sister is
10 and we'd be hanging out this lake and
I'd be like what the [ __ ] is to stop an
alligator from eating us nothing and I
rely remember looking them in the eye
and I'm fascinated by them right they're
amazing so I always loved dinosaurs when
I was a kid that was the sort it is it's
always in the nature I'm always into
like cool nature shows and documentaries
so I'm looking at this thing thinking
like oh we're just used to them being
around like we shouldn't allow them to
be around we're just used to them being
around so we think it's cool that
they're around but they will [ __ ] eat
you know eat your dummy chance they get
so I started buying I buy alligator I
always have infinity pendant always all
my belts are always alligator that's
gangster dude I have alligator bags from
my pool cues keep in
alligator alligator luggage hike
alligators I have an alligator wallet if
I can't do it dude I don't like the way
to kill them oh wow I want to kill them
if alligators if there's too many of
them and they were near you you'd want
to kill them too they're eating machines
they're heartless eating dinosaurs they
got a brain the size of a thumb I don't
like them dude how about the one that
Disney World the parents yes their kid
they're the two euro yes
ate the [ __ ] kid gave no at
Disneyworld they have a real problem in
Florida they have to scan the [ __ ]
property looking for alligators they
have to go through they have waters
there I took my daughter my youngest we
went fishing there there's a there's a
lake that where you go bass fishing it's
amazing there's great the values in
there [ __ ] yeah there is you got to be
careful man anytime you got a body of
your water in his lure the land around
Florida yeah no swimming in Florida
that's my rule no so in those lame
swimming no any row don't know swimming
there's no watersports in Florida that's
the rule get out of the water no ice in
Tampa there you want to go the beach
milk you [ __ ] you and your saltwater
cross sharks sharks you got shark soup
down here [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] you a
ways to die in Florida dude the craziest
thing is happening right now in the
Everglades is the pythons they said that
there's been a 90 plus percent decrease
in the amount of rabbits opossums
raccoons deer like all the major mammals
that live in the Florida Everglades are
gone they've all been killed by pythons
they took a Judas Python you know the
Judas Python is they take a Python they
put a chip in it so they can track it so
they have this male Python and they sent
him out there to find the females and
they used him to locate through the you
know using the GPS to locate a 16 foot
Python 16 foot female Python that was
pregnant game set match yeah so he's
banging these [ __ ] out there may get
him pregnant these [ __ ] are watch and
these evil [ __ ] snakes look at that
is that it snake hole stakes boyfriend
they have to kill it
why also no no they're invasive they're
not supposed to be there it had 73 eggs
and it was more than 17 feet long you
imagine stumbling across that thing oh
you're dead you're dead that thing
weighs as much as you do you're dead
holy
[ __ ] yeah that's probably a 200 pound
snake oh my god that this little
bitch-ass hundred forty hundred forty
getting away from the destroyed get on
my face if I got a knife so he is
staying in the live I got a piece so
hard
go ahead P let's wrap this up
[Applause]